gil how did your kids i mean did they
grow up
are they good uh one of them's a serial
killer
[Laughter]
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to
oh my god
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere
what's his name george lopez george
lopez oh my god
omg omg hi oh my god
gil do you do podcasts at all have you
done them i've done podcasts yeah yeah
i've done a bunch
and since this i've done a bunch of them
since this uh
documentary documentary yeah yeah for me
anyway i've done a bunch of things were
you happy with the way the documentary
came out
i loved
but did you know that it was going to be
the impact that it had though
absolutely not yeah because it's like i
didn't even know about it and i just
kind of was on
netflix and i like documentaries this is
trending so i
pre and i could not stop watching anyway
start were you a fan of true crime
before that yes you're [ __ ] yeah do i
watch all that [ __ ] bro oh right on okay
so
why are people fascinated with with
you don't say true crime let's just say
what's true crime
well not not t not written tv
yeah that other shit's fake crying yeah
exactly right
the category right yeah true chime
they have a literary license to change
it
like oxygen
[Music]
all white people go crazy for daylight
but they love it they love it
not only that they do in my house too
[Laughter]
asians like it too asians like it you
know okay today we have an amazing uh
group of people here here we go
we have uh we'll see that
[Laughter]
yeah so my replacement is is waiting in
the wings right now
let's get to it well we have two amazing
guests today and i want to make sure
that we got my arms are open again now
you got me thinking about it so
yeah we have vietnam veteran turned
legendary
oh my god i'm sorry i don't know what
this dude doesn't do anything
he doesn't [ __ ] research you know i
kind of give him a hint to him like hey
look this up all right i have lots of
things
on him he was a vietnam veteran did you
did we know that reported
well that was the earliest thing that i
have note of him doing that was in the
60s so he was a vietnam veteran he
turned
legendary detective for the los angeles
police department trick-or-treaters
los angeles county sheriffs see what i
mean
the los angeles county sheriff's
homicide bureau for 38 years
[ __ ] compare a sheriff to lapd
i guess i did i guess i already did it
jose
all right everybody with a badge will be
arrested it's been nice talking today
i'm going to
leave this up to you for the rest of the
week though well because bobby was our
special like
we didn't know he was coming he's our
superpower you don't give me a [ __ ]
introduction i'm gonna go ape [ __ ] in
this place
all right this is great put his picture
up here give me a [ __ ] introduction
bro
this is a renowned comedian
i used to play softball because you gave
his history right
i played softball bro you know what i
mean i was molested
oh well i didn't throw that in there
that was molested i had to open my eyes
he caught on fire he was molested
thanks for helping me bobby lee one of
the most ridiculously
funny and good dudes bobby lee
oh thank you it's better to know bobby
lee than to see him from afar because
when you see him from afar you think
he's funny but when you get close you
see like not that doesn't have any
veneer
at all but that's why he said he wanted
to come here so so
true crime can be oxygen channel
id dateline gill sure
gil carrillo by the way yeah we never
got to introducing him i guess yeah i
got chopped down
that part's over bro okay i i'm just
going to sit and watch we're going to
get you a darrell gates poster for your
house
the uh why do why does let's say why
would
somebody make a mistake like that in
thinking that lapd was the only
you know police force that had
detectives don't ask me that i'm a guest
on your shirt you know
you know there's two major departments
here in the in the county in los angeles
lapd is one everybody knows about it
everybody knows lapd
it's like the marines in the army
marines got good publicity going oh my
god
and then you got the army you know
people don't know that
uh we're not we don't roll up the
streets seven o'clock and close our
close our stores we have uh just about
as many to go back and forth
as to how many sworn officers each
department has
the dudes that beat up rodney king were
that's lapd that was lap yeah yeah i get
it
yeah who have their shares beat up
anybody nobody know where they are
they're so good you don't know about it
so so
when when frank salerno was
investigating the hillside strangler
case that was sheriff's department that
was a sure it was a joint it was a joint
effort lapd had some of the cases
as did some of the shares i think
everybody thinks it's lapd
just naturally because of the detective
dragnet
and all the shows that make it seem like
if you're going to be a detective you
can you're only going to be lapd lapd is
the only ticket in town
why do the sheriffs catch all the
criminals we're good
yeah we're second place we try harder
you know i shouldn't say that i don't
start
anything between us they're just they're
just uh
good you know they're dedicated uh it
isn't
you didn't come on this job to get rich
it's a whole another leadership too
there's no
yes similarities exactly
and um when you went to vietnam and you
got out
you wanted to be did you want to be a
police officer yes i did okay
yes i did it was a police officer that
actually saved
saved my life right you know he took me
off the streets had my parents sign for
me i went into the army at age 17.
and after spending a tour in vietnam i
had a new appreciation on life and i
would mature
yeah so do you think that vietnam
prepared you for your life as a
detective
oh no doubt yeah prepared me for
anything i wanted to
do or take on in life you know prior to
that i thought
d stood for damn good and that was
fabulous and so
yeah now i wanted to go to school and i
wanted to learn and i want to give
back what that cop came to me so he took
you off the streets and then when
you know because all those guys that
were kind of bullies in school
and the streets were maybe dudes that
were some were
mean dudes a lot was just feared just
kind of like but if i think that there's
anything that'll
scare you straight is going getting
signed for at 17 and then ending up
in vietnam i mean it's the first time i
was away from home but
forget vietnam just going to basic
training the first time i'd ever been
away from home
wow listen to my mom cry and get into
the iii's as i was leaving
it was it was tough and where was basic
training i did my basic training at fort
ord
and i spent uh thanksgiving by myself
just about everybody else was gone out
of the wow barracks on the east coast
and
it was uh lonely as a first time away
from my family like that
and it was the worst worst thanksgiving
i ever had
the best thanksgiving i ever had was in
vietnam wow why
big weed because there's weed
they smoke it out no it was just that
i was a crew chief on helicopters we
were doing resupplying at the time wow
so our mission for the day all day long
was flying hot meals out to the
troops out of the field and they finally
told us
you know hey guys we got one more one
more left
we take it out and they eat or
you guys have worked hard you stay here
because the mess all will be closed if
we come back
and we said let's go so we took it out
we didn't care about eating wow man
took it out and when we came back the
mess sergeant said [ __ ]
and no electricity in the at that time
of night
he put candles up and he stood in there
by himself and he served us
thanksgiving dinner and it was a
it was amazing it was good wow what does
it say about you though dude because a
lot of dudes that come out of vietnam
right they get like ptsd
right and they have trauma and they have
[ __ ] up lives you know they turn into
alcohol
and you were able to leave that place
and and create
you know a career for yourself you know
i mean what does that say about you bro
well i think it says i got a good family
good
good friends and good support team yeah
because that would have been all [ __ ]
up i'd be like out sucking dick
intermediate and shooting heroin yeah
[Laughter]
when you uh you've been married you've
been married to the same woman
and i think one of the things that's
great is you when you got back you had a
plan you seemed to me
to be someone who remembers dates i was
telling brian that you remember all the
dates
yes but also you
made a plan for yourself i want to do
this i want to do that yes you wanted to
get back with your girlfriend you wanted
to break up with her and hurt her
because she hurt you
which is completely that's us that's
what we do
i got a deer john when i was in vietnam
and so i came back i wanted revenge i
wanted to
get her down and palm my hand and break
it off and watch her suffer like i had
suffered
yeah i got out june of uh 70.
by september 70 had her eaten out of the
palm of my hand
and the day after christmas of 70
december 26th
we got married wow and uh we just
celebrated
our
i think it is all them because they have
a very structured
way you know and i think uh one of the
things that
is noticeable in the in the mini series
is that
she appeared to let you be you
and let you do your work and let you be
whatever you needed to be to be at work
and not make you
live by some kind of like rigid thing
where you should she knew you were
in in your in your mode of beyond a
doubt
uh she's the wind beneath my wings yeah
uh she
is i refer to her uh affectionately as
sister mary clarence you know i'm the
devil she's sister mary
yeah yeah but i think only a specific
kind of woman
can do that like i've had girlfriends
who are like you know
i'm not you're number one no [ __ ] you
know i mean
stand up you know what i mean yeah and
all that's my career i got [ __ ] to do
and my girl now bro is like she
understands i have to go on the road
that every night i have to go up and she
understands that that comes
that's very important to me and that's
probably what your you know wife is like
she
yeah she's fortunate uh we're fortunate
three kids she's never had to work she's
been able to stay home take care of the
kids and
take care of the house and i was just
paycheck coming home
you know yeah and
she's good she's a good lady before
before the cop
saved you what did you aspire to be when
you grew up you
i hadn't told you i didn't come no i i
didn't
think about anything i just think would
i be the first one in my family not to
graduate
right and so i was i had no idea what i
was going to do
that's a that's a fast growing up right
there like
that you'd go to vietnam
come back you may be the only guy that
ever i heard it say
i'm glad i went yeah it was it was a
learning experience i wouldn't wish it
on anybody
but if anybody had to go i'm glad it was
me i could because i i survived i knew
i learned i matured and gave me a new
look on life
it's different uh i remember helping
start an orphanage when we were down
there
wow and uh so to be able to see
when people over here in the united
states think about
all the trouble they're going through
they don't have troubles here you get
you get into war zone you see trouble
i'll tell you why i'm here man can i
tell you why i'm here tell me why you're
here because bro
i i love watching like movies like seven
you know i mean you look at
you know morgan freeman and brad pitt in
that movie like to me
you like i never get to meet those guys
to me you're that guy
oh thank you no honestly dude so it's
like yeah when i told george
when he we were talking about you you
know in the documentary i was like
if you ever have that guy on you know
please call me
i just wanted to meet you you're a good
dude oh thank you and i can't
you know i wouldn't be able to do what
you do like you know a lot of people
look at me and go i can't do stand up
and do the things i do but like with you
bro i can't
even think about like imagine us being
cops no
they would never i would never catch
anybody i think george and i we'd be the
[ __ ] up rush hour
they would be like yeah
can i tell somebody else what happened
i'm an officer
it's
[Laughter]
so so um
being meticulous and then being a police
officer
they heard about you frank did right
frank was like
the protector i was assigned a homicide
bureau he was working homicide bureau
frank
his partner had just retired he needed a
new partner and frank could have had
anybody he wanted
and his partner probably worked on the
manson la bianca
case i'm sure no that was that was all
lapd
oh this was ill-side strangler wow okay
that they had done
the hillside strangler all right yeah um
were you like when he called you and he
was like can you join me were you
excited was that like something like
for me like when i was a young comic and
i had guys like george
you know go open for me you you get this
like excitement of like holy [ __ ]
i'm getting invited into the club you
know what i mean did that feel like that
well
no doubt it was a christmas party uh put
on by the bureau we're there we're
getting a drink yeah and salerno hit me
up
uh hey listen uh you'd be interested in
being my partner and
myself trying to be cool just said sure
you know
that sounds cool yeah and i went back
and sat down and told my wife i said hey
frank stiller just asked me partner says
wow so what what
i said you don't understand that's frank
salerno yeah i mean this guy was a big
deal
it was a big deal uh and he could add
anybody and he chose his
younger mexican and how old were you at
that point
i was 33 34 years old yeah but in your
head do you think like
like if he would ask me i would have
been like yeah i'll do it but like in my
internally i'd be like can i do it like
that's a lot of pressure no
i wasn't afraid of the pres that that
never bothered me i was there's no doubt
i knew that i knew the business
i was learning the business there's so
much to learn and you get better with
time but i
i wasn't i wasn't concerned about my
ability to stay up with him i just
to be with him it was and i knew i'd
learned from him
because he was so experienced and then a
couple of months later
he came by and he phoned me and he said
hey how about meeting me at the station
went to the station
uh in east l.a and he says you know at
the party
a few weeks ago i was in my cups when i
asked you uh
if you'd be my partner and i think okay
now he's going to let me down easy i
really didn't mean it
was in my cup yeah here it is because i
was in my cups i said yeah so was i
trying to be cool and he says well i'm
not in my cups now
i want to know if you still want to be
my partner wow and i said
yeah yeah he said good because i just
talked to the cat the cab's going to
make it happen
so that's that's how we ended up getting
together and i was excited
who was working around rodney carla
uh nicole no what is that why didn't
they call her they called him the dating
game killer
yeah and rodney color was on the dating
game as a contestant
yes but he was a serial killer already
no he got chosen to be the winner and go
on a date
and he called that girl and she got
freaked out by him
and she called the dating game and said
i'm not going to go on a date with this
guy because this guy is
creepy wow and it was rodney akala is
that how they caught them
well it was eventually it was it was a
cold case
uh they didn't have anything on them and
they they finally and i'm not really
that well-versed
other than i know there was uh cheryl
comstock who used to work our
our unit she picked it up as a cold case
and then she put it uh her and her
partner put it together there'd be a guy
that was going around pretending to be a
photographer handsome dude yes
and he would lure these girls into their
his car and take them back and he was
under the guise of taking pictures with
him so he had a lot of pictures of his
victims
i think this is a strange question bro
but um when you said handsome dude it's
like
do you think it's easier do you think
it's easier being a handsome dude as a
killer like
you look at ted bundy right exactly tim
bunny comes to mind right away
right if you're ugly it's probably
harder
you would have had a heart i wouldn't
one kill you're out yeah i mean it
caught him yeah yeah this guy
i'm pretty fast rolled
ramirez you don't see any you don't see
any fat serial killers either you don't
no no no
yeah all right well even ramirez
is like you know he's got the worst
dental hygiene on planet
earth though right when he opens his
mouth he's like the kraken bro he did
yeah yeah but on the outside he had a
fan club remember
yeah yeah and some it's which is
disgusting bro
right when when you have killers write
these killers letter
these women write them letters and [ __ ]
one of our surviving victims
65 year old female she testified and she
described as quite the handsome young
man
so a couple of times he went into court
he combined his hair all back
he looked like he was a florida drug
dealer had on a suit with his hair back
here in ponytail he wore his glasses
so some people thought he was good
looking yeah
so in the beginning he started out kind
of high east la ligando heights around
there like high
in that area of l.a where he was hitting
yeah the first one no the first one
happened march 17th of 85 right there in
the city rosemary
just uh there's it used to be a charlie
brown 60 in san gabriel
just a couple of blocks north of there
and the woman was putting which
which everybody did was putting
groceries in her house and the door was
open her garage was up
maria hernandez had just driven home she
had an electronic garage door opener
she opened it she went inside she was
walking along a carpet runner it was a
condo
she stuck the key in the door while
simultaneously hitting the button open
the garage
that opened the garage as soon as the
garage door as soon as she that's to
close it now
as soon as it closes took eight seconds
the light goes out richard made a
deliberate sound
pounded on a car to get her to look at
him
as he's walking or towards your point
shoulder
position he's walking towards her and
he wanted her to see him and
i had learned in through my
dr robert morneau from cal state l.a
that there's
sexual deviates that that's what they
want to see they want to see the fear in
your eyes
they want to see you frightened then we
went inside and
later turned out i found dale okazaki in
there she was dead
right she got shot in the forehead
close range because there was stippling
that's the unburnt powder
uh from the that comes out of the barrel
of the gun
and she also had a contusion in the back
of her head which means he hit her in
the back of the head first
and you're sitting there saying why if
he could if he could
why didn't he just kill her and once
again
he will tell us later that he was on one
side of a counter with a gun right there
in his hand
waiting for her because he knew
eventually she'd pop up because her
hands went to the counter
and when she lifted her head up that's
he popped right into him
and that was in the city of rosemary
that was his okay
that's our introduction to him yeah as
somebody that
yes right uh shoe print at that time
no no march 29th shoe print
did you do two that night the first
night first night he did too silent you
was number two
that one happened about 50 minutes later
she was in a car driving she was in a
car driving
and uh she was kind of kind of like
tailgating her and she
stopped and said like what's your
problem she stopped putting in reverse
when we called it reverse she put in
reverse backed into a car so she stuck
he came up drug her out of the car once
again he shot her twice in the side
side of her abdomen why didn't he shoot
her inside the car
why did he drag her out and there was no
sexual assault or no robber
at either one of these two wow so uh
there there's something there
we don't get the shoe print though until
march the 29th which is in woody right
there by rose hills
strong avenue which is a street that
runs
east and west and runs right into the
605 freeway
and uh there he left in the villa
footprint
was silent silent knew is that her name
was
she asian yes and the girl before that
was asian yes one was chinese one was
japanese
right but you know people don't know the
difference but anyway
yeah yeah but um but they um
but the thing is is that what's
interesting about richard ramirez is
that
he didn't have a pattern right like if
he was just
killing asian chicks right in the
beginning you know there was a pattern
there but then he
he was diverse in his attacks there was
like old beyond his only consistency was
his inconsistency
right so that's what made it confusing
method of killing you know
either guns shod foot manual
strangulation ligature strange
that's what made life wounds stab wounds
and you were the
the first person to say this could all
be the same guy though right you're the
first one to go this is
one guy and it made it more difficult
because i was throwing in child
abductions as well there was
pedophilia going on and
when you look back on criminal profilers
that time from the fbi and anybody that
studies this stuff
and you look at mo's and doctors
psychologists everybody
it's all predicated on criminal history
and nobody in criminal history had ever
been documented doing
what i was alleging are my theories
so they thought that uh i was full of
hot air but when he was living down so
he's living downtown let's say around
the sea so he stayed at the season
and he would roll in there and he would
change his clothes out in the back
of the hotel and kind of walk into the
hotel
in his underwear and shoes he had his
kill kit his clothes
clothes that he used when he went out to
kill those were kept in a locker over at
the greyhound bus depot
okay oh he had an outfit we called it
his
kill clothes it was just all black black
uh members only type jacket yeah yeah
yeah
and black pants black shoes the
shoes he was wearing were the avias they
were black right
which made it even narrowed it down even
more
wow but there were very few of that of
that style and then
does anybody think that those those
three murders are related
at that time no we we one was japanese
dale okazaki was japanese and there is
no
nothing in between to re
link the japanese to the asian chinese
the caliber of the weapon was the same
but the bullets were so distorted we
needed the weapon
or something more in order to link them
on the 29th there was the zazara case
and on that particular case he
shot mr zazar who was laying on the
couch and he
stabbed and uh cut mrs
azara and in her he cut her eyes out
right and he shot her and there were
also
stab wounds uh down in the pubic area
uh i actually asked him she had a big
cut underneath her left breast
and i wanted to know why and he said he
was trying to cut her heart out but
he hadn't figured on the bone the breast
the rib bones wow so he didn't get
through it
was he a cannibal no there's no evidence
of cannibalism although he never told us
what he did with the eyes
right yeah
we're still keeping it happy it's hard
to be funny
to me so this is like i'm like i'm like
um when you're talking man it's just i'm
in shock almost like there's like
goosebumps on my body
because it's like you know because you
know in this day and age i feel like
it's harder now like i don't think
richard ramirez will be able to do it
now
the way he did it because of the
technology and you know we have phones
you know right do you think he'd be able
to pull it off now
i think so wow you know the only thing
we didn't have then
we didn't have dna uh
then yeah but that would have helped us
identify him sooner
but you know as long as you don't talk
to anybody
you go out and kill somebody and if you
don't talk that's that's why
they get caught they're not smart they
talk to somebody always when
they get loaded or anything or they they
tell their buddy and their buddy gets
popped and he rolls over on him
so you can uh you can still get away
with stuff
all right that's so scary to think about
and
he comes when he comes from el paso here
and then but he was a criminal a little
bit in el paso as well
and he left town i think under some he
didn't have that big of a record there
there was no
no big no biggies he was arrested for
uh stealing from a
uh hotel that he was working at right
and
but there wasn't he got the greyhound
bus here the ground bus here
no he got he got the greyhound bus he
was actually stopped by
by a cop uh lapd stopped him on
wednesday the day
the wednesday before his arrest on a
motorcycle and they cited him for
driving a motorcycle without a license
and he took off on a motorcycle he was
going to arizona then to go to his
brother's house
motorcycle broke down he stopped trucker
said hey i'll make your deal give me a
ride into
arizona you can have the bike and so
that's what he did when he couldn't find
his brother he decided
i'll come back wow he came back in
by this time we had him identified and
we had cops all around the ground bus
depot
waiting for him to go in the public side
um
what we weren't anticipated he came in
on the bus side yeah
and he looked and the informant told us
he'll make the cops
cops can try and look dirty but they
don't smell dirty their air is clean
they don't have rotten teeth right and
he'll make him
so he went in he looked around and then
went out the way the bus came in and
that's how he got out of the box because
when you land on the bus you're in
another area kind of like an
airport and then you so he got a chance
to see
exactly everybody's looking that way and
he's seeing everybody looking that way
and making
he made the cops yeah but at that point
he must know the jig is up
he didn't know really not not until
you know he saw his picture on the paper
ah then he knew
the jig was up and the paper was out
that morning oh i see
and he admitted uh said later that he
was tired
he was tired he knew he knew that
the end was coming but he ran a long way
he ran a pretty good distance from
the he went you know he landed there at
the grand bus deep and went into a
liquor store
they kind of made him in there and they
took off running and you said he ran
across
the freeway he got on then what is now
mta or whatever they call the
rtd rtd it was the rtd then he got on
the rtd
uh went out olympic boulevard at olympic
and soto he actually
saw the another passenger made him in
the paper
and that pastor immediately it was at a
red light so immediately got off the bus
there happened to be a phone booth right
there he went ahead and he saw him
starting to dial
and the bus took off the guy flagged
down
a guy from the gas company in a pickup
and said follow the bus he's on there
he's the man and they started following
him
he went down to about lorena exited uh
got off the bus at lorena
then he started running so he had to run
several blocks probably
by the end of his trek a couple of good
miles and that's going over fences
through backyards
over the sound barrier wall on the five
freeway across
all eight lanes of the freeway
eventually trekking over into the county
area which is just
uh east of indiana on hubbard street no
and that's when the civilians took over
right that's when the civilians took
over but they
they really
he was carjacking the ladies she started
screaming her husband came out grabbed a
pipe
hit him in the head wrong area to do
that and
because of all the commotion the
neighbors saw here's a neighbor
in a fight they know him who's this guy
doing so
richard started running he's tired he's
just been beat
and they don't know who he is and it was
the good people that got him not the
wasn't the hood rats from the body yeah
that's good people yeah it was they were
good they were good people
they held them the cop got there and the
only one that didn't know who it was was
the cop that got there that day
you know he he he didn't know he was he
was a rookie
yeah he did he's like you ever been in
trouble with the law before oh
no right really he was a rookie he did
the right thing called
paramedics they put you know a little
turban around his head stopped the
bleeding
and lapd came across from the city side
into the county area
and they had been following 911 calls
from the city side
hey there's a guy running through my
yard so they just came up
and they said that's the guy we've been
chasing that's our guy
took him right out of the radio car from
the sheriff's department put him in
their car
and took off before this young deputy
knew what hit him yeah oh man wow
and it was funny because the guys from
east la station
they wanted to beat the deputy let him
go
biggest arrest in the history of the
county and you let them go
to the blue to the blue meanies and i
laughed i laughed at them i said hey
listen
had we been chasing him into the city
side you guys would have done the same
thing
who cares he's in custody yeah that's
all that's all yeah
and um i think in there
he's like it's me you know he was pretty
much he was pretty much yeah
at that point he admitted he was it was
him that day that morning
yeah so when is the first time you were
in the room with them ever
that morning that morning yes so when
you because you had you hadn't been in a
room with him
before that i mean you're just chasing
this guy what's your first impressions
of the guy was he
you know normal was he you know i mean
was he a little
wacky i mean what you know he was he was
nothing
to me at that time it's just if you
could imagine being a professional
say a football player yeah well all of a
sudden it's game time
you get ready when you get ready to go
on stage you
joke around but now it's on safe bam
you're pro you're comedian your stand up
right when i go in that room
i can't think of anything else other
than i need to interrogate that guy i
need to talk to him
i want him to talk to me he's human he's
nothing more
and he's caught yeah hey let's just sit
down let's talk
i have no ill feelings towards you and
it's not like you see on tv where
you're slamming hands or cussing and
shouting
so he wasn't resistant he was like you
know you got me
let's talk or was he like he was quiet
quiet quiet initially he's tired he
subdued
he was advised of his constitutional
rights and he he invoked
which means okay we asked no questions
see ya
get up and start walk out he said wait
wait wait wait i want to talk i have
some questions
what do you want to know what kind of
questions you have so sit back down
and he started asking questions start
answering him build up
uh i built up a little rapport with him
because i could relate to him i was from
the streets
i was from a barrio he was from amarillo
so we could talk
and before you know we're talking then
he started talking in the third person
where the night stalker would have done
this or maybe he would have done that
not admitting to anything not that he is
or he did it right but he was talking to
third person
and i was playing with his anxiety level
because i wanted to know what kind of
questions i could ask him
you know what's going to raise his
anxiety or what's going to keep him down
because i want to keep him down here i
don't want him
and at one point in time he had his head
if this were a desk
he had his hands just like this and he
had his head sideways
and i'm talking to him about a very
sensitive part of his life and that's
his sister
and what had gone on
i forgot about that what was the thing
with his sister well i was just talking
about her sister all right
and and i wanted to find out what kind
of relationship
she had had in the family and was there
a relationship between her and
dad and as i'm talking to him
richard started almost to the point of
hyperventilation he started going
and his fist started coming off the
table a little bit
and when they did that for a millisecond
i really did get
a little concerned myself because i'm
sick
i'm sitting here saying if this
something bit starts to float or
levitate out of here i'm gone
oh yeah i i've been in fights i've been
shot at i've been stabbed but
i can't find somebody's floating around
a room and then i realized
he's human guild it's all he is and he
calmed down again and at one point
he was doing this with his hand he was
going like this he was just making a
circle on
top of the desk and i'm looking right at
him and i just told him i said go ahead
and fill it in rich
he's what are you talking about i said
go ahead put the pentagram in there it
doesn't bother me
that's all you and he says you know
about that stuff i said yeah i know
about it
and he goes erased it looking hilarious
just so and right after it's hilarious
is going like this yeah and right after
we took his anxiety level that high
then i said how about a break you want
something to eat right
and so you wanted to get something to
eat we got him something to eat
take a break i'm sorry did he no i
always wondered this stuff did he ask
something for
specific like oh can i have a
chimichanga i mean no no i said hey i
bought a burger
oh right you and he goes burger sounds
good he's oh yeah
got him burger fries and a coke and that
was it
let him eat we took a break then we went
back at him and we didn't ask him much
more
that first time oh but in your back and
forth you know they say manson always
had that creepiness about him just in
his regular speech was he kind of creepy
or was he a normal guy
no he was he's quite articulate probably
one of the sharper murderers i've ever
interviewed
he was and he wasn't like a like a hood
rat from the street
no well he went to the library and he
checked out books he was kind of reading
stuff you know
he told us he he flat out he told me one
day he says hey gil
he says i got an ego that will fill this
room because i can tell you everything
about the
the time the romans fed the christians
to the lions to modern day serial
killers whatever you want to know
so he was an articulated well-read
individual
i think you have to be to survive that
long you know
in that behavior doing that behavior you
know i was around here in that time
you were you were out here right yeah
and
you could you could feel the fear i
don't care where you were like
he went to northridge i worked in
northridge wherever that dude was like
in sun
valley yes out there in east l.a
you might that [ __ ] may have
never even been around you could
feel [ __ ] in your house you could feel
it on wow
outside when it started to get dark
right it was a [ __ ]
feeling of just fear everywhere dude
there was
everywhere fear i didn't feel it as much
as
george did because you're a man
there you go i was so focused on
capturing you know
i was working the case i didn't have
time but you could
anytime i went then he plays if i saw my
wife i saw family members
you know they were i could see it in
them and if you run into anybody that
knew what i was
doing they were full of questions and
fear but because there's a fear though
you would think that you know the
society and
individuals are preparing themselves
right like would did you get
like like everything yeah you got things
you probably you know secured your door
right
it was the first time in my career then
and
stopped afterwards taking in custody
first time i was sleeping with a gun on
my nightstand
wow and my family wasn't there they had
moved out my whole family they were gone
and i just told my wife don't come home
in the middle of the night don't
because i've got a gun and i don't want
to do anything because there was a
murder
or one of the murderers or a few
millionaires were close to your house
right yes and the
diamond bar just the city right next to
us my god
wow but i mean in that feeling of fear
the dude was still striking [ __ ]
people so
you were scared and he was still out
there doing it
yeah he was still out there like like
almost like a guy like he delivered man
everybody's afraid of this [ __ ] guy
they're locking their thing and the dude
still is climbing in windows and still
killing people in the midst of this
whole big
city of fear yeah there's probably like
a lore
that's behind that where people think
that maybe is this guy subhuman or is he
like sure no
maybe well i listen to demon i listen to
some lady
uh as a matter of fact in the netflix
documentary
where she says somebody should know what
this guy looked like he's got to look
like a friend
you know he's he's got to look different
well
killers don't look different television
makes them look different they want to
put the fear factor in you
right but not all killers that lady said
why can't somebody
somebody he's got to have friends yeah
somebody's had to have seen him
why they catch this character which it's
simple it's not
it's not that yeah it's not that easy
yeah do you think his courtroom stuff
though was that an
act or was he just what was all that
stuff that he was doing well he's an
egotistical maniac so he was just doing
for the camera
yeah he'd do it for the cameras he he
was a luster he liked women
there was a day in court and we used to
have a lot of courtroom visitors
that would go in there either college
students high school classes would go in
there
other attorneys and women
and there's one day there were these two
attorneys and they were dressed to the
10th they were gorgeous
and nice business suits just really
looked beautiful
and i got a phone call the bailiff
called me over so i went to the bailiffs
desk
take a phone call and every time richard
walked into the room if you walk from
east to west
when he first walked into the courtroom
he'd scan the audience
to pick out whoever he wants to look at
and then he'd sit down because he was
forced to look forward he couldn't look
look back now when they take a break he
comes out now he's going from east to
west
and he focuses in on the one that he
wanted that he saw away in there well
there are these two gals that are
sitting on the on the edge of the bench
and when he walked by he's smiling at
him
looking right at her the one on the
outside put her hands up to her lips
and blew him a kiss and spread her legs
open and it was you know i'm sitting
there
i went back and told my partner i said
hey lock me up for a while see if it
works for me
you know there was they did it you did
have followers some of the
devil people were in their devil
worshipers were in there
but wow was that
was that drugs that made him the devil
worshiper or the music or this acdc
well but mesa he started using cocaine
and he had epilepsy the cocaine uh
made him made him get into this stuff
and he found out that he was
started hanging around with uh some
devil worshipers
and the booty was getting better so then
he got into it
and he you know at the end after
conviction we spent some time with him
just talking openly and said rich why
don't you tell us you know this will
help us out for future cases
and he said gil i can't tell you that
[ __ ] he says well when i die lucifer
will kick my ass when i get down here if
i tell you anything
i can't help you out like that also he
believed
yeah but he believed
and people tried to convert him into
back to christianity yeah he didn't uh
want it
there was a filipino young lady
and i can't for the life of me remember
her name but she was there almost every
day in preliminary hearing
and i asked him after whatever happened
to her
and he said well she got tired of trying
to convert me back to christianity and
last time i talked to her i talked her
into doing porno oh my gosh
wow she
he could manipulate somebody yeah yeah
wow
so that was uh
i don't know when he was in court and he
was in shackles he did the one chicano
thing that
all the chicano's doing he's like this
and the lawyer is talking about him and
he's like
don't be [ __ ] talking about me
[Laughter]
he's doing this yeah yeah and muttering
under his breath and i'm like oh man
that's like the move that
every chicano does one day school or
whatever
one day coming into court he walked in
shackled and he looks and he looks over
him he goes
and he did that and as soon as we took a
break
took a recess the news news reporters
came running out to
around me just like in that movie
airplane when they all run out and get
in the moment
they come running out and what was that
was that death threats what is it what
was he shouting was that demonic
and the only one that understood was a
reporter from channel 11
tony valdez and tony was laughing he
knew
exactly what he had said yeah and to
this day tony and i are friends
and if he calls me on the phone or send
me an email or anything it's first thing
he says
[Laughter]
that's cool man yeah i mean i was i was
at a book signing
and i'm telling that story and
when you're up on stage all the lights
are you can't see too many out there
and i told the story and all of a sudden
i hear le carrillo
and mr valdez was in the audience sir
he had gone there to the books yeah
and really was it was touching for me to
see him there
so for a dude that had a lot of ego like
that and filled up the courtroom with
people
from all walks of life who just wanted
to i mean that were lawyers right
and after that he didn't want he didn't
really
want to tell how all
all these things were done he wasn't
looking
he still was an egomaniac he his ego
would not allow him to
if he had the information then he's he
kept it
it's like he's smarter than us okay he's
outsmarting us
he has a mental i mean he has probably
narcissism right i mean
he has some mental things that he that
we could treat can you treat narcissism
i don't know
i don't know yeah yeah he asked me one
time where do you think i am the way i
am
and i just flat out told him if i knew
that i'd be a doctor making a lot more
money than i am as a cop yeah yeah i
can't answer it
you know in the beginning you know in
the beginning you know you see
what makes you know i was telling these
guys that there was a guy that i went to
high school with
who was a gymnastics guy strong guy
ended up a security guard at sylmar and
people would go over there and like make
out and he threw
the people over the [ __ ] side of the
mountain and
the guy died but the girl was a little
bit bigger come on come you know be
plus i said with niacin like i don't
know she was a little bigger
and she didn't go out she
and she went down and got caught on
something which was a big you know
yeah so and she climbed up to the top he
just assumed that
both were going to be gone nobody would
ever catch him
he just went over and threw him got him
out of the car so what are you doing he
was a security guard
threw him down and the girl crawled up
and
you know and they got him and and he was
the guy that all the girls
wanted to be around in high school and
this dude's been in that prison outside
on your way to vegas for 40 plus years
wow wow and he would be the he would not
be the guy you would expect
of that behavior of him also you
wouldn't expect him to be a security
guard now that has better be a security
guard
but a guy who had so much promise at one
point could have been a facade
and then he's this guy that's not that
but yet in his mind
he's everybody wants to control somebody
they want it's kind of like that uh pro
football player that uh the mexican guy
that just
committed suicide right junior say oh
well no
aaron hernandez yeah yeah nobody knew
what he was doing
he kept it all man he had a lot of stuff
yeah yeah
they said he had bad cte yeah i think
that's good that has something to do
with that
it make you look for vargas and you're
part-time that's right
he hasn't done it to me i'm taking a
couple of blows
i mean i i i have an interesting
question i think it's um i think i mean
you're
born that way because like i don't know
i grew up like within a violent
household right like my dad used to beat
the [ __ ] out of me with golf clubs beat
my mom you know and get drunk you know
it was just a terrible um upbringing you
know and
i just lived in fear and trauma and i
used humorous defense mechanisms but i
would never hurt anybody or
you know i would hurt myself maybe and
shame myself and punish myself
but you know i think you're just like um
but that you know with the kind of
upbringing i had i could have been a
[ __ ] up guy
right but i chose to make people happy
by doing performing and i also
i go therapy to you know heal my past
and i have trauma therapy and stuff like
that but i just don't think people are
just born that way
do you think that's what it is i have no
idea i
i i find it difficult i'm not laughing
at you but
when you sit there and say you have
trauma therapy you go i only know you as
a comedian making everybody laugh and
funny
to hear you say you have a serious side
you know how can he get up there and do
that he's [ __ ] up yeah
i think that's what i think i think
that's what it is yeah
you know because there's a there's a a
line of that like i
you know i follow crime documentaries
and
i forgot who it was that had the same
thing i didn't have any baby pictures
and i'm a father and you start to think
man
this is almost like the way we go but we
go
the other way like i really want to hurt
i wouldn't hurt anybody
but i knew guys around in my
neighborhood that
were shooting people in high school man
and you're just like
you know you grew up with these guys and
and maybe in three years it changes like
we all go in junior highway i'll
graduate from junior high
and two years later they're doing like
home invasions and [ __ ] shooting
people and i remember
we went to this guy's house and he was
being accused of murder and when we went
there we didn't know
walking over from school let's go see
our man over here
we go in there and he's looking out the
window across and there's
under there's marked cars around him
and i said we said what's going on then
he told he told us we knew
about the murder but we didn't know it
was him
and then when we walked outside he
walked us to the sidewalk
and all the cars are looking at him and
we're right there and he goes
to us i better get inside because i'm a
murderer
and he [ __ ] walked inside and me and
ernie were there we looked at each other
like
we got the we're like what the [ __ ]
happened to our man right there man he
was [ __ ]
the dead he was a [ __ ] devil wow
that's a [ __ ] devil
most of the guys uh generally speaking
from the block that i grew up on
those who went into the service led
normal lives when they came out
and those that didn't are either dead
now or in the joint still oh man it's
true
it's true you know and it's it's no
fault of
i just think once you know once you kind
of get with bad guys like starting with
different guys
well like you said that upbringing
though i mean you had it i think it all
starts in the home personally
i think it does start at home you know
it starts in the home
yeah i guess you know there was still
love in my home like my dad you would
only beat us when
he was drunk you know what i mean and
but at the end of the day you know um
you know they put me through rehab so
there was love there you know i mean
but um so maybe these people have no
love at all like
you know whatsoever any no support
abandonment you know i don't know you
know
maybe something it's something that no
one will ever know really it's just a
mystery
you know what's the guy's loners i mean
richard
came out here on his own yes had a
brother that he didn't even know where
he lived
well he knew where he lived okay he yeah
he did lived right there in east l.a
right he'd just made it just a few
blocks east of indiana
he he'd have been he'd have been home
safe wow hey dude can you give me some
water i'm parched
i don't like telling people what to do
but no no
and and it did feel good
[Laughter]
look at the glass they gave you i know
everybody's got like glasses
he's not one of us they don't know where
he yeah
what are they what do they ask you now
for gil with all the everything that's
come out
with that that you're still you lecture
what does you ask for
the public that uh the the public i i've
had uh
on social media on facebook as an
example i wouldn't take anybody as a
friend
unless i knew them personally right i
don't care if you're friends with my
kids
i don't care i don't know you and i
don't know who you hang with
once once i became this thing went out
and i started getting messages you know
people requesting friendship
and facebook and all and i told my wife
you know i've got to start accepting
some of these people
i've got to read every one of them find
out why i won't
accept them because if not the last
thing i want the public to know
feel that i'm an arrogant [ __ ] right
and and i'm not i'm nothing more i'm no
better than anybody else out there
so i started accepting friends now from
somebody that had maybe
200 friends on facebook uh now i'm up
pretty close to 3 000
since this thing went out i've had
people from all around the world
i've done television for australia wow
canada i've been asked for poland for
uruguay spain
people just asking if i would do zoo
zoom cast fascinating
uh and i've had people uh call up and
want me to work their murderer
and so yeah they don't they don't
realize i was just telling
my wife and i feel very sad
a lady has written the department
and her grandmother's case is unsolved
and so she's asking for help and she
wrote a letter
and asked the department to get it to me
where she's asking me to work where she
on her own is linked it to three other
murders
and she knows that i would have the
ability to go in and work it
and people that ask that have
they have the slightest idea what it
takes and what you got to do the
commitment
i first off i don't have that ability
anymore i'm not a cop i'm a civilian now
right the hours that it takes every just
for every minute if you're going to do
it and do it right and
now i'm i've got a family you know and
i'm retired
and i'm enjoying my grandkids i'm
enjoying life you really are
i think that's great that you are the
times that we've talked and
you know you've been out on your rv and
you've been out enjoying your life yeah
and i just uh i feel sorry for her but
there's nothing i can do for her
and there's a
i without revealing everything
here there's somebody else to contact me
on another murder
that it looks like that one's going to
be solved here soon
you know it's hard to talk about
somebody and not do their name when i
was talking about that guy that was a
murderer that
three times i wanted to say his name so
i know he says you know i've been
working with this
it's hard not to say or let it slip what
it is because i wanted to say the guy's
name
even right there and if if i say it
it clearly will describe like what
happened with
in that situation i'm glad i just did uh
an interview this last week with channel
11 uh
gina silva and one probably the one that
has meant more to me than
any of them uh a guy by the name of uh
salvador du ran from una vicion
from univision and
because he says you're a hero
to the mexican population you are
something special and
they wanted to do a profile for some a
program called
uh unimpacto and so came down we did an
interview and i'm waiting for that one
there because
it it gives them and this whole thing
started
with a friend of mine who's a writer he
was a member of the sheriff's department
and he got injured went off medically
he ended up writing first for the
program chicago pd
and he called me up and i've known his
whole family his uncles who were
members of the department he would like
to do this you know there's
if you look at television today there
are no hispanic heroes you know
everybody's
drug killer robber and
you have a story and we want to sit down
and talk to you about it well that
started about two and a half years ago
i think there might be one hero on tv
but uh no i get it uh
but uh absolutely i mean i i agree with
you're not here roll bro thank you no
but i i
it's one of the things it's one of the
reasons i mean
whatever color you would have been i'd
have been impressed by just
your ability to solve crimes but the
fact that you're a chicano and
prime factor they're the other ones that
speak spanish first
that is prouder for us as chicanos to
have you be chicano
in all those things if i had never even
reached out to you i was proud just
seeing you in the pictures of
leaving the the scene in
um out in while you're doing the job as
a detective
inspiring to us because we didn't think
that there were
people that looked like us that were out
there and i never looked at it you know
it
uh all the years that i worked in the
department
there was no color we were all
investigated we're all cops and i didn't
care
anything about color this and and
just because uh
when i was chief of police interim chief
police for san fernando
a little lady uh was pushing a little
cart
and i i'm big in stature i got out of
the
chief's car and i'm wearing a uniform
and she stopped and i said no no no i
and i told her in spanish
to go ahead i said good morning have a
wonderful day
and she was scared and when i said good
morning have a wonderful day
and please go in front of me and she got
the biggest smile
nobody had ever talked to you know like
hey here's a cop just saying hi to me
and it was really touching to me and so
made a difference so
it it made me feel good so to know that
there are people that
don't have anything like that and it's
not
it doesn't take much uh just to go ahead
and be able to do that
he was the intern chief of the city that
i grew up in wow
crazy yeah it was crazy
and it's it's outside of lapd it's just
a small town city of san fernando
and they still sell fireworks in san
fernando
you people would come from all over
different parts of the valley to buy
fireworks
it's not a big city but it's a
complicated city
with politics and police mayors
and the newspaper the san fernando sun
which doesn't pull any punches pretty
pretty rough
thing and he was the interim chief of
of san fernando wow
dude i'm not chicano i want to be i love
it yeah yeah oh thank you i love
chicanos but um what i loved about the
documentary is
that you know i just don't you know
first of all i i knew who richard
ramirez was you know but i'm not
familiar with the case
but i was just grateful that you got
your credit
you know a lot of times why people
they take all the credit you know what i
mean and it's like
when i saw you in that documentary i was
like oh [ __ ] you know i mean
it just gave me goosebumps man because
it's like
finally this you know someone like this
is getting his his due
you know his the credit that he deserves
you know and then it's like
i'm so happy that you know this [ __ ] is
out there
and you're getting the credit you
deserve man it's because i think i i
think there's a lot of minorities out
there that
did a lot of [ __ ] right and they just
die you know
and no one really knows their
contribution to whatever
they were doing you know and i just
that's what i got out of
almost even somebody that lives their
life honestly
that gets killed by somebody like that's
out there like a predator serial killer
honest people good people and you're
protecting
them but it's a big city a big area
and you got a guy out there like that
preying on
elderly people on weaker people on
females
and you know when you see him
he like you said just a regular [ __ ]
guy
that's all he is and he just had this
lust for for women
but to us this guy was a [ __ ] monster
man like nobody knew where
he was coming in from and not leaving a
lot of
prince horrible crime scenes but just
the i mean
the footprint was everywhere was on the
clock radio it was on the porch
it was in by the side of the people's
houses it was all over the right
so he's out there in these same shoes
it's impressive you've done your work
i've done my work i watched it yeah but
but the guy
russell williams in canada that that was
like the kind of a rapist killer
that he was he flew for the royal
canadian air force he flew the queen
oh yes yes and he ran by somebody's
house and he saw a girl working out on
the
treadmill that kind of triggered [ __ ]
for him and he would still
he he wore the same shoes to the
interrogation
and while they were interrogating wow
you know we got the kind of shoe print
you kind of match it after
a few hours and the detective said to
the guy russell
what can you give me today and
he had a tire print on him also they had
a tire print you drove the car
it was like a like a toyota for you know
like a forerunner 4x4
and then he was wearing the same shoe
print which they got
from the scene and they had him and
when they got him he got really kind of
introspective and he said
you know can i write a letter to my wife
and tell that i'm sorry
and to take care of the dog the golden
state killer the malto had [ __ ]
chicken in the
he was cooking chicken the golden state
killer that was out there
uh forever and when the cops came in he
goes hey
can i turn the chicken off they're like
yeah we'll turn it off
they caught him after after a lot of
years and he was out he was out there
btk btk
creepy i was actually called to go
consult with him they asked me if i'd go
consult with him
on btk and he was out and came back
yeah and about a month uh a month maybe
two months maximum
before he was arrested uh he was
arrested
before i was supposed to go out there
and i called them up and i said i guess
we'll all bets are off that'll be about
a month i said all bets are up you don't
need me anymore.
and they said no no come on out we still
want to consult with you not only that
we put up
we've made a raise for you to help put
on a seminar for us
and so that's what we did a little
training when we were out there and
i was one of the few people got to go
into their room their war room that had
all the evidence and
it was uh it was that was a fascinating
dude and he was just
every day you know he was a deacon at
the church at one time he helped with
the boy scouts
worked for animal control he wanted to
be a police officer
yeah i have a question how come there
ain't no asian serial killers bro
i can't think of one
they just haven't been caught we get
eight pluses and everything
yeah right you're better than everything
smarter than ever
yeah they're all happy but but uh btk
was actually got away with it went a
long period of time when he didn't
he didn't uh kill anyone i believe it
was about 30 years 30 years
and he came back because he
he felt he didn't get the credit that he
deserved his ego wanted to get back
then he started to leave things around
and it was a cd-rom
computer they they followed the they
didn't think that
uh he'd be able to follow him and he
they just duped him
he said he called and said if i send you
guys like a cd-rom
are you able to track that down to where
it came from they said no
wow george how do you know so much about
this [ __ ] girl that's scary you're
scaring the [ __ ] out of me right now
listen you know
but it's just i don't know man it's just
been one of those things that
that um has fascinated me
yeah i would say crime i'm not sure why
but i think crime i don't call that was
a
bad bad guy it was bad his whole life
and i admired him until i realized he
was bad like i you know we admire
uncles that are you know they seem like
a little coo is a little troublemaker
but he
he like beat me up when i was like 14
and that was that was it like he was
like no that's
that's the guy i'm admiring the guy
that's kicking my ass yeah kick my ass
to kind of put me in my place and you're
like well that was
that was a big deal for me too because i
you know in the neighborhood you would
admire older guys that
that i mean there was one guy that was
older
brother he was probably 19 we're
probably like 15. he was dating somebody
who was married a woman
and he would sit on his porch and he
would talk to us
about the things he was doing with this
woman and she was married
and about a month later there's all
these cops over this thing
the husband went to the guy's house
knocked on the door
he opened the door back then there was a
screen door and then the wooden door
he opened the door and the husband shot
him through the screen door
once in the chest and killed him he was
19.
and uh you know he was you know talking
all that [ __ ]
we learned right there not to
really say about anything yeah just
not to i mean first of all not to [ __ ]
with anybody that's married when dudes
were at work
when you work a place and they're the
ones that are flirty and guys are going
out with women that are married and
you're just like i don't know man that
i don't know if that's a that's a good
deal for you guys to be doing that [ __ ]
because you had already seen
a guy who was just bragging about all
this [ __ ] and then a month later
you know he's you could see him you know
the door kind of half open you can see
the dude laying there
and you know that happens all the time i
think that
it does kill how did your kids agree i
mean did they grow up are they
good uh one of them's a serial killer
[Laughter]
they're fine yeah yeah yeah i'm so good
at it i have two girls
and a boy first one was born december 7
second one was born december 7th 1974
and my son was a month premature he was
born november 2nd 1977.
three years apart four grandkids all wow
all of them healthy everybody's doing oh
great yeah well in
in the document in the docu-series you
had a lot of respect for your father but
it's also
from someone who didn't have a father
and by had an abusive father
it's great to see someone raise kids and
to be
what a father is someone to look out
with love and look at
respectfully and to hold dear because it
is your father it's your strong male
figure
it's very important he was old school uh
father
i had six sisters no brothers he had
raised a family of about 10
because his first father passed away
yeah the second father came
in and got caught trying to hook up with
his sister and so they ran him out of
dodge
so he was the father figure to the
family and the boys he raised them all
and he was all about work labor labor
labor
he worked hard and he never told me what
to do he would hint
or suggest you know i had to make my own
decisions though
and uh he's the wisest man that i've
ever met
to this day and all i ever wanted to do
was make him proud of me that's you know
he was
because he was a hard-working man that's
what i wanted and
in the documentary as one of the things
made me cry because
subliminally uh the director on this
thing tiller russell
did an amazing job putting it together
but i could see in
number four there's a picture of my dad
we're at the beach
and i'm about five years old and he's
holding my hand
and i know my dad was proud of me you
know by this thing
absolutely the night that he was
convicted richard
uh i went home and i had never cried as
an adult male
and i got in bed and i was crying like a
baby and my wife just put her arm around
me and said
it's okay your dad was with you and he's
with you
he is with you and so i was with you
you just made me cry bro the the day he
passed away
he uh i had never told my dad i loved
him
so the night before he passed away i
asked everybody to step out of the room
and he was in the hospital and i went up
and grabbed his head and i said dad
i got to tell you something i said dad i
love you
and my dad waited to hear him say i love
you he said
me too me too but i didn't get the i
love you
and so he passed away the the next
morning
and i was at my dad's house my sisters
were there
and i told one of my older sisters a
story you know i just wish
i'd heard my dad say i love you and uh
she came in about 30 minutes later and
said you know you question your dad's
love for you i said no i just wish i'd
heard it says no
you questioned dad's love well let me
tell you she opened up
newspaper says he had this in a steel
box in his room
it was ten thousand dollars cash deed to
the house insurance papers mortuary
everything says you know what look it
and it's all wrapped up in a newspaper
article
about you when i was starting to help
start an orphanage
in vietnam and i was asking
so i know he was absolutely
absolutely [ __ ] movie bro i'm gonna
write a script dude
oh my god it's great to have you even i
know you're not a
law enforcement but i think it's better
for us to know that you're out there as
just a good chicano dude man
raised his kids and and made his father
proud
ah you're a likeable dude bro like when
i saw the dog you're just unlikable dude
like you test well you probably test
well bro
it's got a great voice your face dude in
your body he's got a great
body bro he's got a great voice yeah
yeah his voice is the voice
i'm not in the gateway no no no no
gateway i just
like the you decides i just like
everything about you bro
well thank you [ __ ] dude so glad i came
here man
right yeah i'm just glad you called me
bro oh man
no see the thing is the thing is with us
is
you know we're we're i was watching
seabiscuit
and the [ __ ] the can
had a dent and the guy worked in the
market and he says you don't throw a can
away
because it has a dent what's inside is
still good
and i'm [ __ ] ah oh yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm like
what happened like a trigger
yeah it just goes off you just start
when something's real it just hits you
yeah with and it just you look at a
picture
you hear a line that what did they say
and it didn't refer to you and your
father you made it out you know
and those things for us we go to
the we have to be dark in order to be
funny
but people that are dark all the time
that's not us like we might be
quiet away and dark thoughts but
ultimately we're good in our hearts
because we want to make people laugh
but i've been around guys that were
funny as [ __ ] and they were criminals
and they were [ __ ] you didn't
want to be around
in 11th grade we got a gun pulled on us
guy opened the door he was looking for
my friend kenny
and he pulled a gun in the 38 that went
across my face like this and the guy's
like what the [ __ ] you looking at put on
the [ __ ] has a gun where's your
cousin at his shit's right in front of
me like this i'm like
and then he goes look we have to go tell
kenny i said okay but drop me off at
home first
and he's like no [ __ ] you it's all the
way over there i said hey louie take me
home man
i'm not i don't want to [ __ ] be out
anymore like i don't want to be around
you
i don't want to be in this [ __ ] place
with you guys
and kenny got killed about two years
after and louis spent
probably 30 years in prison wow and i
knew at that moment
that this [ __ ] gun is going under my
face
that i'm like [ __ ] this man i'm [ __ ]
these guys
i know i i ain't getting the [ __ ] out of
here the uh i told you some of the guys
from the block when they were making the
movie heat
yeah i took some of the guys from the
movie heat over the wayside
and they were gonna go because i guess
in the scene in the movie
the girls are visiting their their
boyfriends or their husbands
and so they wanted him to go through the
experience to see what was really like
and so could you arrange for a real
inmate
let them intervene they would be willing
to do this and so i checked i said yeah
i got a buddy over here from the streets
so got him he sat there and they said
okay you want to
take the girls up to the cause when you
go to wayside you go down to
at the bottom there's a visitor center
you have to stand in that line then you
wait
and then they put you on a bus and they
take you up to the jail and they said
okay you want to take them over to the
jail i said no they want the real
experience
have them stand in line just like
everybody else they'll get the real
experience then i had an inmate up there
waiting for him to somebody from the
block
and and that guy they couldn't believe
that he was in jail
because he was a three striker and he
got him from burglary
this last time but yet he had spent all
these years in prison because he was a
third striker
[ __ ] and then he eventually ended up
dying in prison
so speaking of dying in prison though
did what was your last conversation with
richard ramirez
it was in san francisco and just we
didn't have a real conversation just say
pleasantries the last serious
conversation we had was
just before he got transferred up san
quentin this was already
he's been found guilty he's been
sentenced to death so we set
we watched the there was a made for
television movie uh
on the night stalker and we watched it
with him
oh well he saw him crazy right now did
he like the casting
he did he said that he didn't think that
he told me that he didn't think he was
ready to watch it but he didn't think
they'd be able to find anybody sinister
enough
to portray him oh wow and he actually
liked the guy that portrayed him oh wow
he says he looked he looked good he
looked evil and he
acted evil and the guy excuse me the guy
that portrayed richard
had come down my house spent about two
hours and they just want to talk and
learn a little bit about
richard and i remember telling him he
told me
he's hey i'm sure you're going to be
down around the set and if you're on the
set and you see me
don't be surprised if i don't
acknowledge you or say hello because
like
i'm a character actor and i get into
character and i won't break character um
i said okay i said let me tell you
something if i'm on the set
just let me warn you i'm a
character cop i said
don't be surprised if i slam your ass up
against the wall wow
and he looked me so seriously i said no
wow when did richard when did he die
when was he june 7 2013
2013 yes that's so he
there were people upset that he didn't
spend enough time in prison but you
can't i mean he died of cancer
but i mean who cares i i don't i do my
job they said they didn't spend enough
time in prison
yeah i know right he's dead i spoke to a
warden
uh who said in on death row
not general paul on death row after
seven years
of death rows and people start going
nuts anyway oh yeah
why because they're in isolation
isolation right
so and they don't get to talk to anybody
i don't know i've never been up there in
death rows they have
other inmates on the row you know how
they get along i have no idea but is
there like
i mean i don't know much about it so i'm
in a cell right is there like a little
window or something i can look into the
other one or just no wall no
you're in a cell you have bars in front
of you so bart
as you're looking at me right now bars
would be right here yeah
you have three solid walls and bars and
a huge door like a huge medal
you can't see the guy next to you but
you can hear them you can hear them you
can have mirrors you can talk to each
other they
get string and they get weights and they
sling notes back and forth to each other
oh wow that's how uh they communicate
can you draw
i mean could you guys get paper yeah can
i get pen and paper and rod
yes and right and [ __ ] yeah all that
okay can you read
yes read watch television oh they have
tv there yeah
they have their own tvs oh they do yeah
oh cool
it's those old ones like from the
[ __ ] all motels the little plastic
ones
with the radio on the side probably and
a bad antenna all right
yeah well i didn't i i didn't still have
like stream [ __ ] you can't go ahead
right for a hulu or anything i i don't
i don't think yeah right yeah i didn't
like san quentin at all i went up there
once because
uh you go up there and that's the only
prison i've been to they make you sign
up
a waiver you know they don't no hostage
they don't bargain for you
you know and i could just see some
inmate over there hey
fat ass on the line that's the one that
put me in joint and yeah
so and if anything happens just get your
back up against the wall or hit the
ground
cause they'll start shooting and
i didn't need it you know yeah yeah
it's on its own it's its own separated
richard asked
both frank and myself if we would go to
his day that he was sentenced to death
if we'd go to his
uh the day they killed him and frank
responded said your damn rights i will
and he asked me and i said [ __ ] i don't
know
you want me to be there i'll be there if
you don't i won't
because i've seen enough death and
destruction you know in combat and out
the streets
it doesn't interest me to watch you you
don't think there would be any kind of
closure if you saw that
no oh i didn't care to see it i i've
seen enough
you know to some people you look at a
dead body that's been shot or beat or
stabbed whatever it is
and they see blood guts and gore yeah
and i don't i see
something scientific the body's talking
to me and you know i got to study and
see what it says
so i get i derive no excitement i hold
nothing against that guy the guy never
bought me a drink i don't know him [ __ ]
the most vile man i've ever met heard a
lot of people
but once he's not
in custody over here and he's up in the
state he's out of my
i got other things right right you know
before we we went out here
i wasn't aware i don't think bobby was
and brian that
as a detective you went to the autopsy
of the people who were
who were murdered yes for information
right yes you go to the autopsy to
learn more than you saw on the streets
oh fascinating it's just it's just like
how do you so let me i don't i've never
been to an autopsy you know
god willing i will one day but um so you
show
up and is it like they they pull the
body out of a
or is it on a slab or do they pull it
out of a freezer
what happened by the time by the they
they have
they used to have great big just like
great big meat lockers
great big things everything is
refrigerated and they're all stacked up
the bodies are they're not in crypts
they're just all stacked like bunk beds
yeah they're they're stacked up uh by
the time we get there for my autopsy
because we would instruct them i don't
want to be there for your charting the
body so the
doctors get there and they got to do all
this drawing
yeah every nick and cranny on the body
i want to be there for the autopsy
itself so by the time i get there he's
on a steel table stainless steel table
that has drainage
and the head's propped up and then they
just start cutting and they start
[Applause]
is there a smell oh yes awful the only
two things that i never got used to and
all the although
i thought autopsies were fascinating to
me
but i never got used to the smell
because they're
extremely odiferous and
here's what appeared to be nothing more
than prune shears
that you'd prune a tree with to cut
the ribs and the rib cage just go right
through the bone
and to hear that i never got used to
that
have you seen a body like that you know
if you see you know you know the 800
autopsy guy coming from a nacho yeah
yeah fidel herrera vidal yeah herrera
good guy right yeah who's this person uh
he he's he
has 1800 autopsy but he worked at the
coroner's office as well chicano dude he
was a coroner's investigator big guy you
guys were probably around the same time
yes right as a matter of fact
uh he he was transported on some of the
uh
yes night soccer cases we picked him up
at home because he had
some back problems some back surgery we
picked them up and then took justified
then brought them back
right i was just in his office probably
about a month ago
yeah the one over there with the 1800
yeah
so i went over there we'll have an idea
for a show for him
and you know the dell took me over there
and
he had you know he has the whole autopsy
set up and he has
uh the people in the in the
locker and he opened it up and you see
somebody wrapped their head wrapped
and they may have been alive today's
monday they may have been alive friday
and they're in there now over the
weekend waiting to have an autopsy done
so imagine you know somebody that you
know a week ago was alive
oh my god and then they're in there and
he unfortunately i don't think the city
is able to do all of the autopsies that
they
are scheduled because there's too many
right maybe not maybe
he does a lot of pr he does private
private second up
second somebody when you go to the
hospital
they had a problem covet
covert
so with covid 19-0 12 coming up
and they go ahead and it's just a
doctor's signature no autopsy
right but so family members want to know
did he really die of covid so now
they'll pay hmm
rich people people like uh maybe a
whitney houston or michael jackson
those people if they want a private
autopsy want to eat under autopsies
wow so they do and then they submit
their results
because the federal government was
giving
when you died of covid federal
government was re
giving money back to the hospitals and
all this relief
so it's very easy to go ahead and sign
one off not to say that they would ever
want to do that just for the money but
they were receiving money for it
wow that's his job
as a detective now is what's changed
because you you had a way that you
worked with i think is probably
independent of the way that frank did
his work right
you had a you had theories you had the
first theory that
it may have the night soccer may have
been the same guy
and then some people in the law
enforcement lapd laughed at it they
laughed at
there's a website most of my bureau
laughed at me yeah everybody laughed
they didn't no they didn't think it
would be that right they said that's
right no it
can't be do you is frank still alive
yes do you hang with him still i don't
see him that often i just saw him last
week
uh the guy that broke me in at homicide
bureau very dear friend of mine
uh passed away due to covet and uh
he broke me in supported me
he sat in my motor home with me we were
monitoring her surveillance was going on
during the night soccer case
he believed in me and
he said
you're following the freak but he's not
your freak that's
the wrong guy that was that was nice
that was that other guy
you know about the other guy remember in
the documentary the other guy that was a
chicano dude
almost the same mo of things
he was he was definitely a freak he was
a freak and so
our that was our tudor robles and uh
did he live with his mom yeah
and that those like naked pictures and
magazines hidden
i was the best man at two out of three
of dawn's weddings
[Laughter]
after the third one like i'm not doing
it anymore so he's bad luck
yeah no i did the last one
the last one was a winner good wife good
lady
and frank was just there that was last
wednesday so i saw frank oh cool
he lives on the other side of the world
for me he lives on the west side i live
on the east side
we run in different circles and uh
he continued to be a private
investigator he did pi work for a long
time
he was you know if i learned i told
frank in the very beginning if i can
be half disorganized i can learn to be
half as organized as you are
i'll be great unfortunately it didn't
work
he's organized but just meticulous like
with everything i had uh
i'm ridiculous but he's meticulous and
and he's organized so fine if he needed
his book
from a case in 1985 he'd say i need your
book from 85. he'd say okay
and he go and he'd pull it out they'd
say gil we need your book from 1985 and
i said by when
and okay you need it next month all
right about five days before
i'd start ripping everything apart to
try and find what they're looking for
those are those blick uh big black
binders the that's the murder book
that's what we put together
murder books those are easy but no our
notebooks we take all our notes
to put into that big binder did you know
they had a murder book no
yeah i don't want to know about they
carry it around if you watch if you
watch a detective
if you watch it again they leave they
have things under their arms yeah
and that's the they have the murder book
wow
before we forget though who hooked you
up with this podcast
yeah your bandmate i got to tell you
tell me about your band mate bro
big shout out to richard reyes richard
reyes richards
lead guitar player for the righteous
rhythms and he's still
playing league guitar today
unfortunately for richard
was involved in a tragic accident about
a month and a half ago
head-on collision uh thank the good lord
he survived
he's been really in a lot of pain he
just got out of the hospital for the
second time again
uh sunday and uh they cleaned him up he
was bleeding internally and he had some
infection in there
so they got him all cleaned up i spoke
with him this morning he sounds great
but he's the one that called me up uh
right after a podcast he had listened to
the podcast he said hey they called you
up yet and i said who
and he said man i heard him on the air
and george lopez is saying anybody know
gill carry will reach
out so here he has so you hadn't met
george
before this no before right there before
wow that was that was the first meeting
yes because let me just say this when
you first met george though
were you a little nervous or no no yeah
i was i was looking forward to pitching
a little bit just a little bit
i was looking forward to him because
i've i've
paid good money to go see i've been to
at least five of his shows
whoa that's cool and i paid one for one
two at nokia
oh my gosh yeah you did the one by
staples center i bet two of them there
nokia yeah
well you're in the lifetime pass now
yeah yeah
i paid again i i got to go there and
uh i've seen him that's nice i've seen
him around yeah uh
i i love comedy and you know and he
relate and the stuff
he talks about i can relate to
everything from the
the thea that's right there that hey
we're going okay don't let them take my
plate
yeah oh you're gonna you're gonna go to
that wedding no bring me some food
yeah yeah you know everything uh it it's
funny you don't like compliments
no i'm saying i'm gonna say wait till
he's done no no i know i don't
it's uh it's it's it's great stuff and
yeah
so i love so i was just looking so
forward to it
well when i told brian that we talked i
said man i just talked to him once i
feel like i've known him my whole life
so uh it's cool to connect with you and
and admire you as a professional and
also
believe me it's my pleasure this is so
cool and probably the most important
thing is
i've made new friends so it's it's don't
make me cry again bro
yeah that's badass yeah yeah it's all
it's awesome man i mean you know i was i
the reason
we got on the podcast i started to talk
about crime is that i noticed that there
were a lot of
people pretending to be police officers
that drive around have lights to try to
pull people over and i have a daughter
as 25
so i was saying for anybody just in
general sometimes
to not think because you know somebody's
pulling you over unmarked car
or they come up to you and they flash a
badge and you know there's some bad
people out there
and a lot of them are pretending to be
police officers
they pull people over and they're trying
[ __ ] that's
it's wild man i mean but i feel i mean
i'm sorry i feel like you can tell
you can't tell i know
you know you could just certain things
that look legit right there's two dudes
right it's just in terms of like what
they're wearing all that you can't tell
a lot of times when they show those
videos it's it's horrible that the a
person pulled over
because it's like a guy dressed like me
going oh yeah because if i saw you bro
i'm out
imagine him i'd be like oh this is fake
there's no way look at that face
you look like a [ __ ] gentleman yeah
yeah but
but i think maybe we're a little bit
smarter than
okay maybe i mean listen they got a scam
right now where they knock on your front
door and you answer they go did you
receive your ups package or go what
and there's somebody going around the
back uh breaking into the back to the
back of the house and there's sure i
just got a message
a friend of mine that i've known for
years he's coach her son
in football and her 79 year old mother
day before yesterday
got uh there was a burglary and she got
raped inside
you know she was sexually assaulted
inside around 79 years old
right there in hacienda heights not good
have you ever been scammed george
um one time a dodger they were selling
tickets that they had made for the
monday that wasn't a monday game yeah
because they had to win sunday to play
monday and i went
my grandfather sent me over to go buy
some tickets and i bought some for
monday but it was
the sunday game and the [ __ ] man with
the [ __ ] he said to me
and then he bought we ended up buying
tickets for sunday
and then the dodgers won and then they
played monday they played the astros
and they won monday so i didn't feel as
bad cause i already had we already
tickets for monday but they had to win
sunday to play monday and they won
sunday
and then we went the next day that's
another thing i know he's a big dodger
fan
because i see him i see him all the time
on tv when jordan he's in the picture
the commercials doesn't come
out i uh i'm a big dodger fan
yeah and i mean i started going when i
was a kid when they moved over here to
the coliseum
[ __ ] and then got in over here i've had
season tickets
uh first base side lodge level
my last season tickets before that frank
mccourt took over
[ __ ] guy oh he made me hate the
dodgers that guy
yeah i i was at that time i had
i on the on the field level i had aisle
four
row w row r seats one two three four
so right you could see the ball breaking
they were beautiful
75 bucks a ticket plus 10 or 15 for
parking
yeah and then we got notified that
they're going to go up to 125
and i said who am i trying to kid i
can't afford this [ __ ]
and so i gave them up i had to give up
this
and when my mother-in-law lived with us
uh
six years after my father-in-law died
she lived with us she was always saying
oh the doctor's gonna be honest
finally i told the wife because that's
when the spectrum had him
so i told i just told the wife i said
you know what we'll just get spectrum
i'll pay the extra money
just so we can have her stop chin
gondola you know
get her the dodger games and so
she passed away two years ago and i told
the wife i said well we can get rid of
spectrum now she's no no
no no so we watched them
every day my daughter she's been to two
days this year
i haven't been to one i love the doctor
i got
one year they called me down on the
field i was uh
recognized as their hometown hero they
get something they give you a little
and it was cool because my mom
got to sit down in the 500
seats yeah they got her down there and
she got to see her mijo and
it was it was that's awesome i'll tell
you what i can george hasn't asked us
but i have a feeling
that he's going to call us soon to get
us nice seats
we're all going to go to dodgers let's
go let's go i'm throwing that out into
the universe
he's going to make it happen we're going
to get great seats you're going to buy
the popcorn all that stuff you can bring
your wife from here to you
yeah yeah did your dad ever go to dodger
stadium oh yeah
my dad he loved it yeah he loved it i
did ring announcing
for the department uh for the police
olympics
was the police olympics yeah yeah they
had had boxing they had boxing and i and
i remember my dad
he went you got to go he the only time
we got to sit down
on the bottom level the field level was
wanting to get tickets from the boss
because when they first opened up dodger
stadium my dad would park
back in the back where their naval
station used to be
and then we'd walk up all the way up to
the top and
the nose bleed so we'd sit down there
and there's a naval station nobody knows
that that's the bottom over there
and so that was fun he never got to go
with me
when i bought and start buying tickets
and my mom
one day when the daughter of the world
series i wasn't gonna be able to go so i
said i'm gonna sell my tickets i got
four of them
so i took them down to troy's right
across from the call see him
and the news media was covered hey
people are selling their tickets
and so i took my tickets in and as i'm
walking in
a guy from channel 11 was walking out he
had just done a story
and he told his photographer no no don't
don't put the camera away
i know that guy from somewhere i know
him and so
i put the camera back on and it shows me
he didn't didn't stop me but it shows me
they're buying tickets
he couldn't remember for and i just got
in my car and i got out of there and
hurry my sister tells me
she says so you sold your tickets
and my sister said yeah well you know i
wasn't going to use them and you know
clean money for them and she says yeah
mom didn't recognize you
because she said midair said comrade
he's selling he's selling the stickers
so it's something i was like [ __ ]
selling [ __ ] tickets
yeah i call it tv that's brutal it's
such a big you know what the dodgers are
such a big part of los angeles for us
you know like in the 70s and 60s
i went in the 60s 70s and then now
recently they don't work with farmer
john anymore yes
yes and i understand that farmer john
can't even make
the hot dog anymore let alone the name
they can't make that one because
dodgers the dodgers own the patent on it
but uh
why couldn't they work out the deal that
the hot dogs are different now but you
know
there's vegetarian dogs and dogs or soy
dogs whatever
yeah but those are people that eat that
go for a dodger
dog people talk about it they move to
l.a and they're like oh you got to go to
dinner state and get a dodge dog
and now it's not the same dodger dog
it's not even farmer john
i wonder why they couldn't work the deal
out i have no
idea that that that's a pretty good
that's a pretty good question when we
watch it
i went out you know when you go into
7-eleven you see those rollers that are
rolling up dogs i bought one for my
house just recently
and we may make our own dodger dogs and
sit there watching are they pretty good
yeah yeah you know what i'll eat a
[ __ ] hot dog you'll be there for
three weeks still rolling
as long as it's still rolling you don't
have to you don't have chunks taken out
of it
it's got bumps it's got bumps i'm not
but if it's still rolling it still
looks oily i'll eat a slim jim i want
anybody
no i don't want to die with a slim in my
in my system but i i'll [ __ ] around
and get a slim jib or five and eat them
late at night
and you're not supposed to but the but
the dodgers in changing ownerships when
we grew up there was just so the
o'malley's owned it
and you knew that things were going to
be the same
i don't want to go and they don't have
that carnation malt but i'm
i'm sure that's probably been gone
forever the chocolate malt with
spoons we still had them last year the
year before last cause they go last year
and you know the more things change over
there the more they resemble
what people love about going to dodger
games
i'll say that i've heard i i really want
to
those uh new home run seats they have
out left field running yeah
those are cool some guy caught two balls
the other day you want to go and sit in
those
same guy i don't care let's go let's go
it's almost like a [ __ ] hammock
because
that was the place where the homeroom
would go over and people that were in
line
eating trying to get it would rattle
around under the pavilion now they made
they sold there bobby between the
wall and the first seat they made seats
in there yeah home runs
it's pretty cool you get uh [ __ ]
dodgers
i've sat in every place in the in the
stadium
except okay except for the new new home
run you want to bring your girl or not
sign how many tickets to get
i'll bring my girl my girl's a huge
dodger's favorite i gotta get bring my
girl
two two one yeah yeah and now one for
your nose and you all right
wow let's put a good run today i [ __ ]
bust you right away
he beat him up and broke his nose he was
[ __ ] like that when i pulled him over
i didn't break his nose that's what
caught my attention the nose
the nose banded well thank you gil
i appreciate you man and we're going to
take you out to uh
all of us are going to have a oh my god
hi night at dodger stadium
and we're going to sit in the in those
dodger seats the home runs thank you
thank you i appreciate it and thank you
for the invitation
you know what it's going to look like i
brought my baseball club but there's
going to be a bottle of [ __ ] secret
seven in the [ __ ] myth
when i was growing up but thank you yeah
man thank you brother
i appreciate you coming here it was a
dude it was a blessing man and i'm
so glad to be here man thank you so much
be yeah thank you so much bro thank you
you guys are too good
an honor thanks very much kill career
everybody
detective shares department
thank you and and a chicano legend an
icon hero
you